welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question it's a show that gives
you too much information about which cap
has the strongest risks what that's our
question that's what I researched and I
have no regrets I'm a her class this is
Phillip Melina I'm a deeded risk what I
actually ask what is this episode going
to be about them because about the new
Captain America legacy and yes it may go
- that's right yeah [ __ ] Winter
Soldier seems like that's the big
question of that show is like who's
gonna be the next Kapoor who is worthy
estaré en that torch or that shield so
what exactly is the big question for us
this week okay which cats
well which caps and you have
possibilities are most likely to become
the true cap and carry the shield in the
MCU from now on okay yeah and that that
is an important question because we
found out this week actually or last
week that Carl Laemmle Carl Laemmle
[Music]
we found out this week that Karl London
at into the cast of the Falcon Winter
Soldier
we don't know specific details about
whose character is other than there's
some speculation that he might be
playing Isaiah Bradley who in the early
2000s was a black Captain America with
all these characters in it there's also
the the drama between Sam and Bucky who
is worthy of the shield and I bringing
in a u.s. agent character so it's kind
of sounding like it's gonna be the
succession of cap shield or like HBO
succession they're gonna play Bor on the
floor for the shield what would that
even look like that's a different thing
but it's based on it okay here's the
deal I counted 12 potential candidates
for with people who have claims for the
shield if they wanted to come forward
and say you know what I deserve to carry
the shield they could do it the MC was
established twelve different people to
do this these are like Baratheon
bastards yes yes don't go through them
all but they're really you could clump
them into three different groups based
off of what direction em so you might
want to go in categories one might say
oh come on daddy don't you love me like
my pain this more than go gee I'm a
little boy you see you're applying last
week's rules of daddy leather Danny Eric
Eric - this week this week it's just the
level never be okay with this thing
you're doing of calling me daddy okay
the first category we're gonna talk
about is the what I call the on-deck
caps the immediate success caps on caps
on Dec the people who have already been
established in the MCU people with names
and faces and actors playing that and
will appear in upcoming properties
specifically the Falcon Winter Soldier
which has its l5 cap options the first
ones the of this one Falcons
Sam Wilson that was the chosen successor
by Steve Rogers he handed the shield to
him at the end of endgame he's going to
be the the central figure of the show we
already see him in trailer footage
discus tossing shields to the tree and
he's video in pretty well but is it a
mistake that it went into the tree or
was it intentional like being like this
shoot that was not intending to hurt me
yeah because cap what he's great with is
bouncing that shield ricocheting and off
of things and by wedging it in the tree
was that a mistake or did he want to
down that tree that's racist because
it's racist complementation we
implantation sir rain yeah but I think
shield handling ability is a good
indicator in barometer of someone's
worthiness to be cap because if they
can't handle that shield get out of the
kitchen you know but the second option
is Buffy of course so Bucky is the one
that a lot of fans wanted to carry the
shield after Steve Rogers handed it off
lifelong best friend he's carried the
shield he has carried the shield in the
comics the problem is is that he in this
universe currently has a reputation of a
terrorist and an assassin and do we
really want that person to be the bearer
of Captain America I kind of do but you
could see how Steve's like maybe the
public won't accept you as Captain
America more than this guy who's like a
veteran's counselor and a soldier
already okay so the third option that
this show is presenting to us is u.s.
agent John Walker so white wrestles
joining the cast as this new government
approved poster boy cap successor he's
got his own suit he's got his own shield
we don't know if that's the same shield
that's all it really takes and you know
that's a good point because like what
made Captain America in the 40s right it
was the Super Soldier Serum but really
it was more about propaganda Randy yeah
there's all branded so whoever the
government says is Captain America in a
sense is Captain America it's kind of
like Santa Claus becomes Scott Calvin
because he looks like yeah you put on
the suit you're the big guy now in the
comics US agent is kind of this
villainous figure and I've speculated we
released a video earlier this week that
US agent could be kind of a puppet
that's being controlled by Zemo in the
same way that he tried to control Bucky
in the Civil War film which brings us to
another candidate Zemo those emo is
joining the story and in the comics Zemo
creates the first iteration of the
thunderbolts and they all take these
patriotic you know Pro heroic facades
and his is citizen V so citizen V
originally was an English guy who his
father killed back in the war and then
he stole that identity and Zemo the
youngers mo stole that identity to be
kind of like a Captain America esque
figure to try to be a replacement
Avengers or Fantastic Four it didn't
work because the rest of the
Thunderbolts turned against him but
Daniel Bruhl as Zemo is joining the
story that could be his kind of sea
mystery plot is by filling that void as
a new Captain America trying to steal
that legacy and I think Captain America
as a brand they try to follow the path
of the American flag and it being
occasionally problematic right like so
for instance the southern flag that a
lot of states have issues with should we
still use them or should we should we
take them away it's having to
acknowledge that being the
representative of America is not always
necessarily like truth justice in the
American waiver sometimes it's like I
think I took out the dictator in a
country but then it turned out the CIA
just wanted him out because they want to
put in their own dictator somebody like
we've have a dark past and I think that
this is the best thing that ever
happened to Captain America is that he
kind of starts to realize his allegiance
isn't necessarily to the people that are
always right and these characters
complicated me even further or
essentially like bad guys but they're
still like look at me I'm wearing Stars
and Stripes I must be good yeah
flags and political allegiances change
meaning over time and I said decades go
forward it's you know kind of like we
all had that decal of Calvin pissin on
something on our cars on our mats now
it's not as fun to have that on your car
because who wants to encourage little
boys beer they didn't you pay enough in
bed already it's disgusting
and our fifth option in case all these
warring factions in Falcon Winter
Soldier are irreconcilable we still have
old cap old man cap is still alive in
this world yeah what's he doing now
Peggy's dad knows what a woman like to
do some crossword puzzles they like to
feed some dumb but he can supply also
bench 500 you know oh yeah that guy's
yeah he's ripped tight 80 I think we
discovered right so he is he's still
alive if they can get Chris Evans to
come back we're just an old man who is
he off-screen he could say you know what
I'm taking my legacy back because none
of you have really earned this it's like
when Jay Leno tried to take back the
Tonight Show exactly Yap is his family's
cars now ok and that brings us to the
newcomer to this cast Carl Laemmle who
some diverse aims playing Isiah Bradley
who was a black cap and that kind of
brings us to our second category the
Bradley family category Kappa Gorham
around thank you got them right so
there's an interesting possibility with
this Malcolm winter soldiers show and
that the showrunner is this screenwriter
named Malcolm Spellman if you know
Malcolm Spellman
Madeline's one of the best writers this
guy is super talented but he's also
extremely outspoken about issues of race
every project he works on he's kind of
like the tip of the spear for race
relations for for bringing the stuff
into our work he wrote on Empire he was
going to produce that show Confederate
honey right you know they're very kind
of lame because they had the the Game of
Thrones guys at the top of it they
should have just had Malcolm Spellman I
be like the the face of it it was going
to be an alternate history in which the
Confederacy won the Civil War it's like
a man in the high castle but instead of
like the Nazis winning it's like the
South winning reign what the modern-day
us would look which goes on what I was
saying earlier to just this idea of like
we can't have a dark history we do we do
and I'd be surprised if Falcon Winter
Soldier with Malcolm's bowmen on that
writing staff I'd be surprised if it
didn't address race in some way so
that's why I think like going into Sam's
family history and bringing in a
possible Isiah Bradley because his whole
cap journey in the comics was it didn't
like shy away from race he leaned into
it it was kind of like a not a what-if
scenario but it was like the same thing
that gave Captain America his powers it
was almost like a Tuskegee Airmen type
story where what if these these black
men were given these powers Isiah
Bradley was like a black Captain America
who was given the Super Soldier Serum
and then we see like throughout the 20th
century the different ways that
intersects with society so all of like
black celebrities and other black
superheroes worshiped the sky the way
Steve Rogers was kind of worshipped they
all like admire his patriotism and like
what he did for his people and what he
did for his country he got to some
controversy during World War two ended
up game pardoned by Eisenhower he's this
controversial figure but he's super
interesting and then so that's another
option if he's in the show you're kind
of giving me kill monger vibes a little
bright like it's controversial too but
he kind of has good points it's
provocative yeah and the character of
kill monger especially in the recent
iteration of black panther was based on
Malcolm X who was kind of saying we need
a revolution in society and in the same
way there's a lot of intersection with
the ideology of Malcolm X with with
Isaiah Bradley as a character and
Malcolm X is in the comics and like
likes this guy and he meets with him and
they everyone kind of makes these like
pilgrimages to like see this guy
to meet with them that are in oh you
know I wonder if there's a another
statement being made there where Captain
America supposed to be a reflection of
the state of the of the state right in
the State of the Union and then if it's
time for like a revolutionary type say
we need to like raise the system and
bring the underprivileged into power and
kind of shake it all up and that kind of
goes with the revolutionary figure where
it sounds like I say it is yeah and you
can imagine a version of falcon winter
soldier this show where he's kind of
like this this old retired version of
cap that never got the attention because
the government didn't care about telling
that story but falcon has the new
successor to the shield Sam Wilson might
dig into that history and discover
someone like Isiah Bradley and be like
how have I not heard your name before
but that if that ends up happening in
the show brings up our next option for
who a successor could be his grandson
Elijah Bradley and this is an actual
baby sexual baby Wow a baby cat a baby
cat or the baby Avengers cartoon show
we're pitching so Elijah Bradley is the
Young Avengers character named Patriot
so Young Avengers more recent comics
iron lad Hulk lien Wiccan stature Kate
Bishop as the new Hawkeye and he he has
like kind of these superhuman abilities
that he says was from a transfusion from
his grandfather a blood transfusion that
gave him that Super Soldier Serum we
find out that that was alive he was
actually using a mutant growth hormone
to try to enhance his abilities the rest
of the Young Avengers were like Elijah
you don't need to do this so you're a
great team member we will still want you
on this team so he's like okay I'm gonna
stop I'm gonna go clean and he leads the
team because he's got great natural
athleticism he's got a great strategic
mind kind of like how cap is compared to
the other Avengers is not a strong he's
still superhuman but really it's because
he's a good leader and he's just like
got a good war tactics mind that's what
that's the world Elijah place to the
Young Avengers and you could think if
Marvel and face force trying to set up
the future you could definitely see a
scenario right where like Sam Wilson
looking back in the past finds his
untold history of an older black cap and
he's out of the game now but he's got
this grandson who could be maybe Sam
wants to say Falcon but his lesson that
he learns is to pass on the she'll do a
younger generation setting us up with a
new young Avengers in phase 4 and phase
5 isn't there also a version of Patriot
that is like the result of
Isaiah's in prison they stole his semen
Oh God it's like they like forced I
think there is like a spin-off where
Josiah X is the name yeah it's they they
tried to make a spin-off that they were
you know yeah that's just a very
personal story someone's stealing their
semen no it's how I was made oh yeah
okay good I'm glad you don't know that
someone's stealing their semen
it does I put it under my pillow every
night and then when I come back it's
gone that's a day 16 there but speaking
of scaley possible hypotheticals let's
move on to our final category category
the what if caps so now that we're
expanding into a multiverse kind of
these hypothetical scenarios are weirdly
possible cuz Marvel is kind of saying
we're in a multiverse of possibilities
now we're not gonna tell you which one
we're gonna stick with or which ones are
gonna be canon or maybe they'll all be
cannon but we have seen so first off
Avengers end game ended with Captain
America living his life with Peggy
Carter in an alternate timeline as young
Steve Rogers so theoretically Marvel
could still show what that alternate
history looks like like we could see
young Chris Evans live in an alternate
26:1 history talk about big questions
one of the biggest questions is what the
hell did he do for the last like 7
exactly like did he tried to subvert
history or did he just try to stay off
on the sidelines did he go rescue Bucky
did he fight alongside Bucky and Peggy
or they're a whole nother also this
what-if cap is what if it's still just
erupt it's still just Chris Evans but he
didn't get frozen right so what I'm
saying is there's a possibility where
young Chris Evans Steve Rogers could
still exist still carrying the shield
fighting the same fight this cap as
we've seen before
another option is we've had the what-if
series coming up on Disney Plus and
we've seen some footage some animated
cells not a full trailer yet but like
the different conventions have been
shown in the first episode we've seen a
limited footage of this and animation
cells of what if Peggy Carter it's got
to say Brian Josh
guns everywhere America um yeah and I
already do Steve Rogers as a skinny dude
is still in that story so we see how
lady was and she like carries everywhere
come on
so we could see like a version of a
reality where Peggy Carter is capped
like a female cap you know so that's
another what-if
but then in a ventures in game there is
also a little throwaway line where they
mentioned a character named Braddock and
Braddock is Brian Braddock captain
written who's a version of Captain
America who oversees the Captain Britain
Corps which is a league of
interdimensional Avengers who help solve
problems across dimensions so there's an
implication that in this multiverse is
going to be governed by a Captain
Britain core right Captain Britain a
British version of Captain America is
going to be someone who carries a shield
but in addition to a British cap we also
have a Russian cap yeah coming up in
Black Widow Red Guardian Alexei Shuster
Cove played by David Harbor who's like a
handsome hunk if you asked me if you
were to ask me who I would want
currently in the MCU to carry that
shield moving forward I think David
Harbor has definitely paid his dues the
guy's been in prison his entire life
he's Russian he was a brainwashed by the
Soviet culture but like he's still
fighting the good fight and he is just
he's got a awesome red suit that still
fits
I can we showed also that I've always
loved the idea of Russian cap the
thumbnail I made once had a weird chin
in the goatee on our DJ yeah I you think
David harbors hot cuz he you think
that's what you're aging into I think
it's my best chance the pretty Gollywood
leading man yeah
and our final option this is one that
you recommended but I had honestly
completely forgotten about him but he
technically exists in the MCU as it is
as a cap surrogate and nuke nearing
sepsis who is shown in just good worst
guy ever not a great guy but he just to
catch you guys up if you didn't watch
testicle Jones Frank Simpson is kind of
a daredevil adjacent former soldier who
now works in the private sector and so
he's kind of a cat figure in that he
went through the same kind of
government programs weapons Plus program
that was connected to Captain America
and Weapon X with Wolverine and his
whole thing is he has three different
pills of red pill a white pill and a
blue pill the red pill he takes to like
get amped up on adrenaline the white
pill he takes to stay balanced between
missions and the blue pill he takes to
come down and the analog forward in the
Marvel Comics with with Frank Miller was
it was connected to soldiers who have
PTSD and have addictions to painkillers
and opioids and they take pills to have
different that's the two real part of
you have really liked the part that he's
being insane and he likes it paints a
flag on his face and he's just like I'm
Captain America too so it has yet to be
seen how much of the Marvel Netflix
world AMC is going to adopt hopefully
some of them see some people are saying
that Charlie Cox might still get to be
daredevil he would be great of Jon
Bernthal is Punisher and it sounds like
I don't think are gonna find a better
actor we play Punisher so pick and
choose Keitel but anyway so we have 12
different options here you have the
three categories that I mentioned you
have the immediate successors who will
probably explore how the Winter Soldier
also the Bradley family who could be
introduced in that show as well and any
these kind of what-if options that might
be explored and during multiverse future
installments but there are a lot of
different options really I think the
best barometer is how well you operate
this shield yes I think that that's why
I say Falcon because I'm like Falcon is
a human being without extra strength and
he's he wedges the shield in a tree
gonna be easy I think we should try it
out it sounds like you already bought a
toy or something Billy didn't know me so
well so what I do did you get a Captain
America shield um no but I got the next
best thing a frisbee are we trying this
right now yeah let's go outside and give
it a shot how people are gonna see I'm
wearing shorts again okay we're gonna
try to prove something Eric thinks
frisbees are gonna be the way that we
figure this out frisbees equal caps
shields it's proven it's science so we
came to the only trees in Burbank
California at these two historical site
trees a true cap is a cat who can
ricochet his shields to three times
so we have a tree here a tree here and
then the statute a stated historical
landmark
[Music]
it's too many cars because it's gonna
land in the street I'm not a good for
it's powered cow oh no sorry
okay I think the problem I've been
having is I've been throwing it like a
frisbee when really the word I've been
throwing it like a frisbee oh I've been
trying to the worthy ESCAP throws it
like a discus which requires you to hold
it across you get it
what did I say it hit two branches
ricochet ricochet ricochet ricochet and
it took out a bad guy that you guys
didn't see from Hydra I don't think
that's even how you determine it to me
much more impressive that a human being
can wedge it into a tree this is for
Falcon here I got a wedge a frisbee in a
tree I nailed that tree but this thing
has rounded edges but this is not what
the shield end is so I have an idea can
we cut for a sec I'm gonna fix this okay
get up oh my god okay I had to go to the
hardware store really quick but now we
at least have a chance of wedging it
into this tree and a chance of killing
someone well what do you think of cap
shield is for
[Music]
a piece of bark came off that would be
someone's flesh I think there's an issue
with this metaphor not only is this not
like a shield it's a plastic rounded
thing with some modifications but trees
are really freaking hard have an idea to
make this more even shield is to tree as
killer frisbee is to whoa mama mia
that's a watermelon okay this I think we
might have a chance with
[Music]
well well well turns out well that was
interesting
I can't go back to jail I think the big
takeaway from who will carry the shield
in the future it looks like burr now
it's going to be Falcon but there's a
possibility that this new show Falcon
where soldier will set up Falcon to pass
it on to a even newer era of Avengers
so that Falcons can stay Falcon and
won't have to like merge character
identities because that might bump some
people out but it's clearly not gonna be
either of us but that's probably what
God intended all right let's move on do
some bite-sized questions that Philip
will answer for us there in the box
let's do this well you can get the box
to take it away okay so our first
question is Thor defeated certs are
easily but couldn't even hurt hello
while search or defeated hella easily
how is that possible what am I missing
here you only do watch if you do watch
Ragnarok kind of quickly it is like wait
the bad guy that he beat up at the
beginning is the destroyer of love all
of Ragnarok canon is the prophesied one
and hellas the villain the whole movie
and this thing can defeat hella pretty
your statuses are shifting actor it does
change but it actually is totally
covered in the movie a really easy what
does it see it - as you can see at the
beginning that searcher is only like
three times bigger than Chris Hemsworth
at the in the early part so Christopher
Hemsworth is the same as main six three
and then if you multiply that by three
or so he's maybe about nineteen feet or
something so he's like not short but I
ain't that big look at him at the end a
giant's the size of a city he's a class
um so you can both combine that the idea
that of course if he's bigger he's more
destructive but he also has higher
durability increased strength all these
things so he's like insane to try to
defeat in that scenario huh but it's
specifically because if you remember in
the movie Odin had taken his power
source away the eternal flame right
before and this is the version of
searcher that has gotten the eternal
flame back so now he this is what he's
actually like and he's actually one of
the strongest figures to know Marvel so
that does make sense that he acts
can defeat hella and in he's the
prophesied one to destroy so it's the
idea the eternal flame wasn't there and
now it's back and that's why you can
basically have been bulking gotta okay
so our next question
when Tony collapses an endgame near the
beginning Captain Marvel says she's
gonna pick up some sort of elixir what
was that you guys take care of him and
I'll bring a misery and elixir when I
come back yeah it seems like a quick
throw away yeah yeah get back in your
room she is referring to basically
chicken soup but it's kind of the
equivalent but it is cool if you do
follow the the idea of the saurians
what she actually is referring to is
this race that theoretically remember in
the aliens movies how eventually it's
kind of revealed that maybe the
precursor to like humans you're kind of
like it got really complicated there is
a Marvel version of that and it's that
the saurians actually word the initial
basis for what eventually would become
humans Kree Scrolls any any of these
like main humanoid figures that we
interact with a lot or actually just
them experimenting with their own DNA
and then eventually that evolves into
the rest of us
so the saurians have theoretically these
pharmaceutical abilities that can cure
things for any of us on a DNA level but
it you know kind of as a panacea that
like maybe it's a cure-all I it's
complicated to try to get into too much
because it's like oh can you just bring
that back and I cure cancer yeah why is
it Carol Danvers doing that all like
it's pricey yeah get back in your room
yeah no she sucks
so our final bite-sized question ooh
so we actually asked her discord fans
yes what Marvel villain would make the
best president so this was a question
from us to our discord patrons and fans
on there and then I'm just gonna read
some fun answers that we got on there so
a lot of people thought Doctor Doom
would make a really good oh sure yeah
he's brilliant um pointed out he already
rules a country so he has that
experience he is brilliant
he's
in the country that he rules but a lot
of people also were like that's too easy
because he already rules a country so
they talked about green goblin which
green goblin actually I think in in a
specific story has become president and
I remember a Norman knows when I was
like in middle school or something it
was all the villains or recon president
at the time looks with her and stuff too
I like this person didn't understand the
question perfectly so there so the
question was which Marvel villain would
make the best president and he said to
Chawla just Black Panther and then we
said we said villains and they said Oh
evil - chocolate which is great there
was talk about danos actually has some
good ideas but he would Institute a
purge
almost immediately yeah my favorite
answer was Wilson Fisk oh yeah he is a
man of the people but he's a billionaire
and those never mislead us but they're
also he becomes the mayor of New York
and a daredevil company I don't know
something about the MCU Wilson Fisk -
that guy like I could I could vote for
that yeah he's got art right he's a man
of the Arts and isn't afraid to get his
hands dirty
yeah with a car door right and this was
maybe my favorite answer that I don't
agree with foot it blood is my favorite
answer is somebody pointed out well Star
Wars comics are now published by Marvel
okay so Palpatine is technically a
villain and so they think Palpatine
would be the best president what I was
thinking about that was you never really
hear about Palpatine's platform like he
could have great ideas what if he's like
instituting a galaxy basic income like
really helping a lot of people I mean
isn't his ideas just what the Nazi ideas
were just like he doesn't do do like
genocide he does aggressive force with
you doesn't killed all the Gaea notions
oh and he also blows the most epic level
of genocide that's ever happened
he kills planets we don't know if
anybody's on now he's not checking these
are his minions he's like I don't like
that probably one said I just heard
millions of voices scream out and that's
Obi Wan's problem he was trying here
though he was trying to make a highway
and there was a planet in the way and he
was gonna create a bunch of jobs anyway
I do think that it's worth noting
Palpatine was elected a senator at one
point so at some point he gave good
speeches and had a good platform well
yeah he is elected Chancellor to from
exactly after valorum yeah doesn't make
it okay so as Hitler was elected to
don't bring him into this every week
he's always in it okay thanks for
sending us those bite-sized questions
guys we have time for one more a more
personal question
personal variety the wet one wet segment
the wet one
okay so this was we should do a show
called Wet Ones all right the gamer MJ
asked us who's the first kiss was worse
I like our game our MJ assumes that we
both know each other's first kiss and
happen on a race was worse well it's the
same story so okay yeah it's an
interesting question because you have to
figure out where you start counting your
first kiss seems like because we all
have like random kisses we had kisses
with family we had many many many Oh
back to see ya learn but there's also
like you know your high school the
birds-and-the-bees hookup relationship
where it's like this was my first kiss
ah yes this one counted or like you know
when you're 28 and you meet your
girlfriend like this is my first kiss
once a you keep changing what you what
you actually think oh now that was the
real one okay so my first kiss if I were
to go way back and say okay good this
this kind of counts it's not it wasn't
terrible the kiss itself was fine it was
the politicised
things that were going or the context is
what made it early decide there was a
girl in first grade who got air called
rhea six well she had a crush on me and
she sat next to me and at one point she
kissed me on the cheek and she had a
crush on me a picture of lil Eric EP
cute yeah okay but like a couple months
later we were lining up after recess you
know the boys line up and the girls line
up and a boy in front of me turned
around and kissed me on the cheek I
don't know boys do you appeal
that's all your man I was just kind of
thrown by it but I don't think you know
kids are just exploring they don't know
what a lot of it means and I don't know
why he did it but that girl immediately
turns over to me not him to me and
points and goes oh you're gay what makes
me sad about this story is like clearly
as a six-year-old someone told her that
that was wrong and gross right and it's
the ill that kind of haunts me that she
thought it was disgusting
and that she like blamed me for it and I
think she's part of it was she was just
like angry at herself rejected I let
myself fall in love again Angela he said
he wouldn't do this but I felt so bad
for him because like he probably felt
some shame for like putting me in that
situation who knows why he did it
maybe he's like the straightest dude
ever but like all of that kind of put me
in a state of shame of like kissing in
general is wrong because the the version
of the heterosexual version of it was
also felt kind of like mean and dirty so
as we got older we we were at the same
school in an eighth grade she ended up
being like the most like strictest
conservative like her parents wouldn't
let her read Harry Potter well she was
she we all had to do like a speech
project where we had to like we're
learning oratory and she did a speech of
about why abortion needs to be like
globally illegal and she ended by doing
this stupid poem about like the unborn
fetuses in her monologue
don't kill me mommy and I point to you
said and Eric's gay so yeah that was my
first kiss and that's why it was
horrible it wasn't like anything
disgusting about it it's because all the
people around it made me feel horrible
about it for years we we you and I have
known each other for a really long time
I've never heard that story before but I
also sometimes I'm so vividly reminded I
guess that our growing up was so
different I guess where I'm like Oh cute
you were like kissed on the on the cheek
I was I was gonna turn 13 but I was
already saying I was 13 because it ended
in teen 12 teen and so I got invited
some girl that I barely knew to go to
Disney World with her family trip I
think she was like taking pity on me cuz
I didn't have money to go to Disney wow
you are a dad it turned out it was like
like all the kids that were like the our
age roughly it was like a girls trip but
I I got to be on it and then you know we
go or whatever and then it's the night
of the first night that we're there and
we're all having to sleep in the living
room of the hotel you know like not to
like lobby but like the the main common
area though and just like a bunch of
like young girls and me but I didn't
even realize to I was by far the
youngest I wasn't 13 yet and her cousin
was there and she was 15 turning 16 and
it's the middle of the night and I
suddenly feel that someone's waking me
up and it's the cousin Bethany from
Pennsylvania and she I had never met
anyone from Pennsylvania this boy uh and
she just starts like pulling me into her
and she starts kissing me and I'm like
holy [ __ ] this is my first kiss and then
she gets completely naked
you were 12 in the common area 12 2013
12 in this like Amin area with like a
grown-up on the couch and stuff and
she's completely naked and I'm wearing
more clothes now needs to wear these
it's so well I and she starts like like
getting my hands and kind of like
showing me stuff to do and I'm like
freaking out like fireworks like going
up in my head
we just kissed for like 15 minutes or
something and then and then I go weep
then she's a little like distant the
next day and her mom is like all the
moms are saying like all right everybody
exchange contact info and they're not
doing it and her mom kind of hits her
and goes go get Phillips screen name for
her pray I am just like okay and so
she's like what's your screen name and
she writes it down and so I and what's
yours and I cherish it and I like to
take it the whole way back to Miami and
then I get on and like as soon as they
get home and I add her as a friend and
she you know comes online door opens and
I say hey sup it's Phillip and she goes
you're a loser don't ever talk to me
terribly because I didn't know this is
owain recorded well it's it happened it
was recorded in here and in here and now
it has to be recorded
oh yeah she was so mean those mean it's
go ever Bethany from Pennsylvania I
still love you though we can make it
work you got kissed on the cheek though
you free kisses it was you you were that
young girl well that's our show guys
reminder to send us your big questions
using the hashtag big question also no
I'm not going for a high-five but I'm
giving a high-five to Danny who sent us
some dope-ass fan art on Twitter and our
discord
we love fan art here's his fan art fan
art this is great this is the most
handsome America's ever look by the way
and I'm friends with Batman Tommy I
think that's Tommy Tommy is our bad
Tommy's Batman I'm pretty sure no time
so send them to our p.o box you can send
them a legit or you can send questions
you can send anything to our p.o box as
long as it can go in the mail but almost
anything yeah subscribe to this show
here on youtube but also subscribe to
the podcast version so you can get audio
versions of all this stuff so you can
listen to while you're driving and not
have to like watching youtube video
while you're driving cuz follow Phillip
at Phillip Malina follow me at EA boss
and follow new rock stars on Twitter and
on Instagram so you can keep up with all
of our stuff and remember to check in
with us next week cuz we'll have a whole
new big question for you responsibly